bonjour nous sommes le jeudi 22 janvier
merci de nous rejoindre dans filcho
votre émission qui revient sur
l'actualité économique locale on
commence tout de suite avec les titres
de cette édition
elle est annoncé cette semaine la neige
devrait bientôt tomber sur le
département les services de VO sont déjà
milisé nous verrons combien coûte ce
dispositif spécial neige il travaille à
l'université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
à l'UFR de Sciences et c'est un artisan
nous avons rencontré un souffleur de
verre spécialisé dans la recherche la
société canopé lance son drone roulant
une première en France nous vous le
faisons découvrir avec le portrait de
l'entreprise enfin dans notre entretien
cette semaine nous allons parler de la
Silver économie l'économie au service
des senéniors nous sommes avec Fabrice
Leloup bonjour bonjour vous êtes le
directeur de familying service une
entreprise de service pour l'aide à
domicile et aux personnes âgées basée à
trappe nous reviendrons sur ce sujet
avec vous mais avant cela passons en
revue l'actualité de la
semaine je vous le disais en titre les
températures baissent vous avez dû le
constater les flocons de neige attendus
dans le département pour ce mercredi ne
sont pas tombés mais pourtant les
services de voi étaient t tous mobilisés
le plan hivernal est lancé depuis le 15
septembre le 15 novembre pardon et cela
jusqu'au 15 mars alors de quoi s'agit-il
et surtout combien cela coûte-t-il
regardez ce reportage de la
rédaction pas encore de neige mais les
saleus sont prêtes le plan hivernal est
déclenché depuis le 15 novembre une
procédure qui s'appuie sur une veille
météo des patrouilles de terrain pour
constater l'état des chaussées et des
patrouilles de vérification des
traitements ici à la casqui on se doit
de veiller sur 150 km de voie
communautaire 10 sleuses d'intervention
sont sont disponibles 20 chauffeurs se
relaent selon un planning d'astreinte
ainsi que cinq bénévoles agents de
l'agglomération qui sont présents le
soir le weekend et les jours fériers
tout cela a un coût qui varie d'une
saison à l'autre en fonction de la météo
et donc du nombre de sorties une sortie
en préventif revient à environ 15000 €.
un budget d'astreinte à hauteur de
600000 € est ainsi provisionné on
provisionne l'astreinte ça ça ça ça ça
s'impose hein c'est contractuel et et
bien sûr on on fait des moyennes euh
donc on est à peu près à 5 sorties par
saison donc on part sur cette base là
s'il y a besoin de budget
supplémentairire bien sûr on sollicite
les services financiers pour
effectivement débloquer l'argent on a un
budget spécifique justement puisque il
est pas question bien évidemment
d'arrêter le service pour une question
budgétaire ça s'impose à nous et on doit
faire face et bien sûr
répondre donc on a une ligne dédiée à
quoi s'ajoute l'achat du sel cette année
la casassquie va reprendre vendre le CEL
non utilisé de l'année dernière depuis
le 15 novembre les équipes ont salé à
quatre reprises en prévention la
dernière fois c'était en début de
semaine le 1er janvier 2016 la casquille
va s'agrandir de cette commune elle va
passé au nombre de 12 avec celle de
plaisir les clés sous-bois Villepreux
morpas et coinière l'amendement qui
permet cette évolution a été examiné et
voté aujourd'hui par la CRCI la
commission régionale de coopération
intercommunale de quoi représenter une
force économique certaine avec
l'intégration d'entreprises comme le
siège social de déco à plaisir ou encore
l'entreprise zodiaque mais également
toutes les zones commerciales ce qui va
faire du Grand Saint-Quentin un pôle
prioritaire dans le département écoutez
l'interview de Michel logier au micro de
Catherine jilado on va représenter un
point économique important ne serait-ce
qu'en terme de commerce on deviendra le
premier pôle commercial des ivelines et
nous serons aussi dans le top 5 des POS
commerciaux de la région î-de-france les
entreprises aussi regard le monde
économique est fortement représenté du
côté de plaisir les clés ou de mort
pacinière donc ça sera aussi un gage de
d'une richesse économique encore plus
importante et une peut-être une
complémentarité qui sera renforcé donc
on sera encore plus efficace et on va
peser beaucoup plus comme on le peser
jusqu'à jusqu'à présent dans l'équilibre
qu'on peut avoir avec les autres parties
de la région de France à trappe l'école
de la deuxème chance était proche de la
la cessation de paiements en fin d'année
2014 l'école aurait pu fermer ses portes
mais grâce aux nombreux soutiens reçus
elle va continuer à accueillir des
élèves pour cette année la structure est
financée par différentes entités dont
l'État la Région l'Europe ou encore la
taxe d'apprentissage elle propose aux
jeunes déscolarisé et sans diplôme de
réintégrer l'école avec un vrai objectif
professionnel au total elle a réussi à
boucler son budget de 2 milli et demi
d'euros pour 2015 écoutez son directeur
Hervé Demar pour 2015 pour pour pouvoir
équilibrer le
budget on aura une subvention du Conseil
Général qui a été votée fin décembre et
et qui représente 100000 € et qui sur
ces 200 millions et demi nous permettait
d'aboutir à un équilibre et et et donc
de de mettre la machine en route et puis
après aussi on peut travailler avec les
banques le deuxème patient ayant été
implanté du cœur artificiel de la
société Carmat située à véis villacoulé
se porte bien opéré en août dernier il
est sorti de l'hôpital et rentré chez
lui le 2 janvier 2015 l'homme de 68 ans
peut vivre presque normalement l'étude
clinique va continuer l'autorité de
santé exigeant que quatre patients
soient greffés pour évaluer et valider
cette prothèse révolutionnaire cette
bonne nouvelle annoncée en debut de
semaine a directement impacté l'économie
de la société ivinoise qui a vu son
action en bourse s'enver elle a pris
16,33 %. je vous propose maintenant de
passer à notre entretien de la
semaine
donc cette semaine pour notre entretien
nous sommes avec Fabrice loulou vous
êtes je le rappelle le dirigeant de FAM
link service une société basé à Trapp
alors vous proposez des services d'aide
à domicile également d'auxil de vie pour
les personnes âgées en situation
d'handicap c'est ça oui tout à fait
alors hier vous avez animé une
conférence donc sur la Silver économie
pour un club d'entreprise à 50 an alors
tout d'abord est-ce que vous pouvez
m'expliquer qu'est-ce que la Silver
économie alors la Silver
économie c'est un termeez
euh c'est en fait une filière qui a été
créée par la ministre des personnes
âgées en 2013 Michel delonet et le mot
silver en fait veut dire cheveux blancs
donc c'est l'économie des seniors
cheveux gris c'est ça silver c'est
cheveux gris cheveux
gris et donc donc du coup alors voilà
c'est pour c'est pour les seniors nous
étions hier à cette à cette conférence
je vous propose d'écouter le deuxième
conférencier qui était présent donc
jacqu Weber qui est médecin gériatrique
à La Verrière je crois qu'il y a un vrai
problème hein toute façon c'est un défi
pour les années à venir vous savez que
la population
va en tout cas de plus de 60 ans va
augmenter de manière très très notable
he ça va représenter à priori plus de 30
% de la population dans quelques années
donc ça concerne une part importante
avec les problèm bien évidemment liés à
vieillissement sur le plan des maladies
sur le plan de la perte d'autonomie de
la pendance choses qui sont pas
complètement hucidé à la fois sur le
moment de la prise en charge du
financement alors c'est un vrai problème
de de société l'économie aux seniur ne
cesse de se développer 53 % de la
demande française sera le fait des
seniors en 2015 vous vous avez fondé
votre société donc en 2010 donc c'était
une une reconversion est-ce que ça a été
par rapport à cette problématique ou
juste problématique de de service alors
en fait mon objectif en créant familying
service donc c'était en 2010 c'est
c'était de m'orienter vers le maintien
des personnes âgées à leur domicile donc
effectivement on rentre complètement
dans l'objectif de la Silver économie
qui est de de trouver des solutions
euh au domicile de façon à retarder le
plus longtemps
possible l'entrée en établissement à
l'hôpital ou en maison de retraite
d'accord parce qu'en fait en dès 2010
est-ce que c'était voilà une quelque
chose que vous aviez senti vous étiez
renseigné dessus comment ça sétait un
peu passé oui alors je me suis renseigné
bon déjà ma femme est médecin
généraliste donc ça m'a permis aussi
d'avoir quelques informations et et puis
euh le le secteur des services à la
personne était en en plein essort donc
je suis arrivé sur un secteur connu avec
un souci effectivement de répondre à une
demande croissante hein le
vieillissement de la population est
quelque chose qui est identifié depuis
assez longtemps qui va
s'intensifier il faut savoir qu'en 2060
20 % des Français auront plus de 75 ans
et du coup il y a il y a beaucoup quand
même de d'instituts pour accueillir les
personnes âgées ou même les les seneurs
à la retraite s'il y a une vraie volonté
donc pour les seigneors de rester chez
eux de rester dans leur environnement
oui tout à fait alors la difficulté
c'est que sachant qu'il va falloir
beaucoup de personnel pour ass des
personnes à leur
domicile la Silver economy développe des
solutions techniques et c'est là toute
la
nouveauté qui a été on va dire lancé par
Michel dellonet sur ce qu'on connaît
comme la Silver Valley par exemple à
ivri sursène où une centaine de
start-ups se sont installés la Silver
valallley voilà c'est un espèce de
cluster où les start-ups les entreprises
sont sont regroupées et elles peuvent
travailler ensemble et aussi se
développer comme ça voilà et et parmi
ces start-ups par exemple il y a une
société qui est établie à Saint-Quentin
comme blue Lina une autre Doro dont le
président est aussi président de la
Silver vallleée voilà donc on est dans
un écosystème qui se construit ça fait à
peine un an donc c'est à mon avis
aujourd'hui encore un bébé mais ça va
progresser effectivement les services à
domicile s'inscrivent totalement dans
dans ce secteurl par le côté humain
d'accord est-ce que vous vous avez senti
le votre demande vous avez augmenté
votre travail le nombre de salariés par
rapport justement à cette demande aux
personnes âgées oui la demande elle est
croissante et notre difficulté
aujourd'hui c'est pas de trouver de
nouveaux on appelle nous bénéficiaire ou
client ce sont c'est de trouver de
nouveaux salariés pourquoi c'est
compliqué c'est c'est un secteur
difficile peut payer parce que
effectivement les tarifs sont assez
réglementés h et
euh difficile et on a beaucoup de mal à
trouver de des candidats et aujourd'hui
moi je suis obligé de mettre des clients
sur liste d'attente par exemple d'accord
donc c'est vraiment un secteur qui
recrute énormément il y a pas c'est un
problème de de de profession enfin il y
a pas assez de de formation il y a pas
assez d'école ou d'orientation peut-être
à l'école il peut effectivement manquer
d'école hein il y a une association sur
le secteur qui s'appelle amadom qui
favorise cette
professionnalisation mais je pense qu'il
manque encore de moyens pour satisfaire
la demande qui va être de plus en plus
importante donc vous êtes passé de de
vous avez commencé tout seul dans votre
entreprise en 2010 maintenant vous avez
combien de salariés alors aujourd'hui on
est 40 salariés mais on pourrait se
développer encore et finalement on se
développe pas tellement par manque de
candidats et vous traitez combien de
personnes à peu près sur donc 50 Enel le
territoire nous avons 150 bénéficiaires
aujourd'hui est-ce que justement ement
les ivelines c'est un département où il
y a beaucoup de personnes agé il y a
beaucoup de demandes peut-être dans
l'île-de France ou je sais pas dans le
sud de la France quels sont peu les
départements moteurs dans ce secteur
alors moi je connais peu les autres
départements les Yvelines
effectivement y a une population
vieillissante il y a il y a une comment
dire des statistiques du conseil général
il manque 600 postes sur le sud Ilin par
exemple donc il y a je ne suis pas tout
seul à travailler sur ce secteur là mais
pour satisfaire les demandes de toutes
les associations et entreprises d'aide à
domicile par an il faudrait 600
candidats de plus dans le sudivline
d'accord donc c'est vraiment un secteur
qui qui recrute énormément on parlait de
de Blue Elina et de Doro alors eux
proposent on a fait des reportages
d'ailleurs à ce sujet dans notre
émission il propose des objets connectés
qui vont avec des services enfin c'est
un espèce de de pâack comme la montre
notamment connecté qui permet de de de
gocaliser les les malades atteint
d'Alzheimer du coup est-ce que voilà
c'est c'est une une demande qui va de
paire il faut qu'il y a l'objet et le
service ou juste le service comment ça
se développe un petit peu alors ça va de
paire parce que le Conseil général
finance la téléassistance à domicile
c'est-à-dire des boutons ça c'est la
téléassistance de base mais ça peut
aussi être une montre GPS qui permet
d'éviter la fugue des personnes
atteintes d'Alzheimer donc les ces
systèmes existent déjà sont proposés aux
personnes dépendantes
et leur permettre de rester le plus
longtemps possible au domicile donc
c'est c'est des nouvelles technologies
on peut dire la Silver économie elle
s'adresse au plus de 65 ans oui je
dirais même un peu plus encore plus de
75 ans parce que donc en discutant hier
avec un directeur de de maison de
retraite il me disait que la moyenne
d'âge d'entrée en maison de retraite
était 88 ans d'accord et donc est-ce que
est-ce que justement il y a pas un une
espèce de petit problème avec ces objets
technologiques pour maintenir les
personnes àissile alors que justement
c'est des personnes agés qui sont
peut-être un peu réticentes justement à
les utiliser voilà les personnes âgées
d'aujourd'hui sont très réticentes ont
peur d'Internet donc on va dire que la
Silver économie va s'adresser peut-être
à la future génération celle du baby
boom et c'est une génération qui est
déjà connectée qui a déjà des
smartphones Doro prépare déjà un
smartphone pour les les seniors donc on
prépare on va dire la Silver économie
dans 10 ans où il y aura un vrai marché
pour ce secteur d'activité on parle
aussi de la domotique donc c'est un peu
les maisons intelligentes avec des
volets qui vont se déclencher tout seul
des des alarmes et CEET qui vont
prévenir si la personne tombe par
exemple est-ce que justement la
domotique c'est en concurrence avec les
services que vous vous proposez la
domotique fait partie de la Silver
économie hein vous parlez de détecteur
de chute ça fait partie de capteurs
comme la téléassistance qui sont
proposés dans les bouquets de Blue Lina
ou ou d'autres sociétés après la
domotique un peu plus large de
confort pourra être proposé à des
personnes un peu moins âgées qui sont
plus sensibles à la technologie mais le
le marché pour les personnes dépendantes
est est encore
naissant est-ce que par rapport à vous
votre donc vos vos clients vous avez
l'impression que l'offre est en
adéquation avec la demande où est-ce
qu'il manque encore des choses peut-être
des services peut-être à développer
alors
euh nos clients ou nos bénéficiaires ont
en moyenne plus de 80 ans et ils sont
pas encore très sensibles à la
technologie donc c'est pour ça que on va
dire que les produits qui sont
développés aujourd'hui par les start-ups
vont s'adresser aux futurs clients qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas dépendants
d'accord je je vous propose de regarder
maintenant la question de la semaine
nous vous av nous avons demandé à à vous
aux ivelinois ce qu'il manquait aux
seniors selon eux quel service pouvait
être amélioré regardez des maisons de
santé par exemple ça manque un peu dans
la dans la région puis
peut-être des maisons de retraite aussi
on dit qu'il y a encore des mourroirs
des espèces enfin qu'il y a encore des
mourroirs alors si ça existe c'est qu'il
y a pas assez de service mais c'est
l'argent toujours l'argent je sais qu'il
y a des communes qui organisent avec des
des des bus il ramassent les personnes
angées il les emmèneent dans des dans
des grandes surfaces il leur permettent
de faire leurs courses et puis ensuite
euh ils les ramènent chez eux c'est pas
mal ça puisque bon euh grâce au service
social maman a pu bénéficier vous savez
de la télé télé je sais plus comment on
appelle ça la téléassistance téléalarme
elle a un petit boîtier euh qui qui lui
permet en cas de de problème bien de
d'être relié à comment dirais-je un
service alors on l'a vu sur sur la
dernière réponse de cette dame la
Tassistance elle a du mal à nous en
parler le problème de la Silver économie
c'est que c'est pas assez connu il faut
puiss en parler il faut plus communiquer
dessus c'est ça oui tout à fait d'où la
volonté de Michel delonet de créer une
filière de faire du buzz autour de la
Silver économie que les Français
comprennent ce que ça veut dire ce que
ça implique il y a même un salon à Las
Vegas où on parle d'objets
connectés la poste par exemple propose
un service nouveau pour effectivement
per le déficit de courrier donc beaucoup
de sociétés dont des grands groupes
comme Orange ou la Poste se lance dans
l'aventure et bon c'est un secteur
d'avenir et bien merci Fabrice lou
d'être venu sur notre sur notre plateau
je vous propose maintenant de passer au
chiffres de la
semaine 3,6 % c'est l'augmentation du
plafond de laapa la loocation
personnalisée d'autonomie dans les
yelines cette décision a été prise par
le conseil général et elle est effective
depuis le 1er janvier 2015 les tarifs de
remboursement des aides humaines et des
aides ménagères sont donc revus à la
hausse par exemple le département
rembourse pour les services prestataires
20 € et 10 centimes par heure pour les
jours en semaine la pass s'adresse aux
personnes qui au-delà des soins qu'elles
reçoivent ont besoin d'être aidés pour
accomplir les actes de la vie
quotidienne ou dont l'état nécessite
d'être surveillé régul iement je vous
propose maintenant de passer à notre
partie magazine avec le métier de la
semaine c'est un métier peu commun
beaucoup de gens pensent que c'est un
art mais c'est aussi une profession
scientifique le souffleur de verre ne
fait pas uniquement des vases ou des
sculptures nous avons rencontré Fabrice
Zucarelli il travaille pour l'UFR de
Sciences de l'Université de Versailles
50 an neline il a accepté de nous parler
de sa profession les images signées et
le dimoine
il met son art au service de la sciences
fabriiscarelli est ingénieur d'études
dans La Verrie scientifique depuis 20
ans comme un souffleur de verre
traditionnel il crée des pièces de toute
forme de toute taille mais c'est avant
tout pour la recherche au niveau de
l'université on fabrique des pièces qui
sont très spécifiques on a par exemple
des appareils un peu comme ça qui sont
euh des assemblages de différents
diamètres de tube de verre et au final
on obtient des pièces un peu plus
complexes qui ne peuvent pas être
réalisés mécaniquement ou dans
l'industrie il faut savoir que dans le
verre dès qu'il y a deux épaisseurs de
verre donc il y a un verre et un
deuxième en dessous ça reste de la
conception et non de l'industrialisation
le travail du souffleur de verre
scientifique reste artisanale tout est
fait à la main il faut être minutieux
rapide et précis la la technique est
presque la même à quelques détails près
lorsque on met le verre dans la flamme
il y a une lumière orange qui se dégage
et on ne peut pas voir ce qui se passe
donc on a des verres très spécifiques
qui permettent de filtrer justement tout
ce dégagement orange et qui permettent
de voir réellement la fusion du verre
dans la flamme petite ou grosses pièces
les commandes sont spécifiques le
matériel ordinaire tube ballon ou autres
airlin sont fabriqué industriellement
Fabrice lui des pièces plus complexes
avec son tour c'est le début d'une pièce
donc on est en train de je suis en train
de former une boule pour pouvoir
concevoir la suite de la pièce
après le verre une fois qu'il est mou le
fait de souffler ça permet qu'il prenne
du volume donc on souffle dans deux
possibilités soit pour gonfler les
pièces soit au moment où on vient faire
des soudures chaque université compte un
souffleur de verre dans son UFR de
sciences en France il serait une
cinquantaine des des formations
professionnelles en ver scientifique
existe au niveau CAP ou bac
professionnel mais pour être recruté par
une université il faut passer par le
lycée d'Orient à Paris faut savoir qu'il
n'y a qu'une formation en France qui
délivre une formation reconnue par par
l'État sur la verie scientifique qui se
trouve à Paris
et après il y a il y avait une autre
formation qui est les néonistes où
effectivement là on va plus on va dire
vers l'art de nombreux souffleurs de
verre exercent dans des entreprises
privées si les postes en faculté sont
peu nombreux les universités sont
toujours en demande avoir son propre
souffleur de verre permet un travail
plus ciblé mais surtout de réaliser des
économies lorsqu'on fait de la
réparation bah on fait la réparation à
moindre cout une pièce qui vaut 500 600
€ 700 € on va les réparer ça va coûter
un ou de 2 € alors que si c'était pas
réparable bah il faut réinvestir dans
une nouvelle pièce donc là ça reste
aussi très intéressant d'avoir un
souffleur de verre et de pouvoir
justement récupérer le maximum de
matière pour pouvoir le retravailler
dans ce domaine l'expérience est un
atout précieux il faut plus de 10 ans de
pratique pour devenir un souffleur à
guéri et nous restons dans le
scientifique ou plutôt le technologique
avec notre entreprise de la semaine
c'est tout de suite
canopé est la première entreprise
française à fabriquer un drone roulant
télécommandé implanté depuis 2007 à
Montini le Bretonneux la société compte
de salariés elle a accepté de nous faire
découvrir son tout nouveau drone roulant
regardez ce reportage avec William l et
roman
rpinet vous connaissiez les drones drone
volant voici le drone roulant il
s'appelle camquad et fait la fierté de
son constructeur l'entreprise
inimontaine canopé on est les premiers à
le faire en France aujourd'hui on a des
fabricants de drones volant qui se sont
penchés sur la question aux États-Unis
ou à l'étranger et surtout la nouveauté
c'est que nous on le développe à partir
d'un système existant pour faciliter la
maintenance seul drone français
construit à cette échelle il mesure près
de 90 cm de long et peut aller jusqu'à
90 km à l'HE téléguidé il permet une
captation d'image fluide et stabilisée
le camcat ça part d'une idée un peu
farfelue au début on a des clients de
parc animalier et l'idée c'était
d'arriver à avoir des prises de vue
qu'on a jamais d'animaux donc vu de vu
de très près il faut imaginer que le
camquat peut être équipé d'un d'un tray
sur lequel on va mettre un buisson ou un
faux rocher pour vraiment accéder au
plus près des animaux sans les effrayer
c'est dans cet atelier que le drone est
né Édouard Janier a lui-même pensé le
concept et construit le petit robot
c'est énorme voiture télécommandée sur
cette voiture télécommandée on a enlevé
la la la carrosserie qui avait aucune
utilité on a supprimé quelques pièces et
sur les pièces restantes on a greffé
notre système la prise d'image les
drones ce n'est pas nouveau pour cette
entreprise de communication si elle
existe depuis 2007 c'est l'année
dernière qu'elle a commencé à proposer
des prises d'images avec drone en plus
des services de création et
communication traditionnel tout ce qui
était communication interactive
fonctionnait plutôt bien mais on avait
un tel problème d'achat im AG de
fourniture d'image original on s'est dit
on va évoluer et puis on s'est aussi
rendu compte que c'était très frustrant
d'avoir un film uniquement fait par
drone même si les images sont tout à
fait fabuleuses on pouvait pas
uniquement avoir des images aériennes
d'un monument ou ou d'un événement
canopé constate une demande grandissante
pour ces petits appareils leur
utilisation se développe il se rendent
utille dans des domaines parfois très
éloigné du marketing ou de la
communication on peut aussi avoir besoin
de nous pour les drones par exemple pour
pour aller faire du diagnostic un
assureur qui aurait besoin d'aller voir
l'état d'une toiture sans mettre
personne en danger on va être capable
d'emmener un drone et puis d'aller bah
d'aller voir ce qui s'est passé et dans
quel état et la structure le camquat
peut aussi avoir cette vocation là
c'estàd d'aller dans des dans des
canalisation laallocation d'un drone
coûte environ 1200 € la journée une
somme presque modique à côté de
laallocation d'un hélicoptère qui
revient elle à 2500 € de l'heure seule
contrainte l'utilisation des drones
volants est très réglementée pour les
particulierers comme pour les
professionnels la législation fait qu'on
pourrait fabriquer des drones mais on a
des accréditations à avoir par la DGAC
qui sont très longues l'avantage du
camquad c'est que c'est beaucoup plus
facile à à produire c'est déjà aussi
moins dangereux parceque un drone c'est
pas un jouet et puis c'est pas soumis à
une législation particulière donc à
partir du moment où on est capable de
conduire une voiture télécommandée on
peut utiliser le camcad le camcad est
encore un prototype Édouard Janier
espère le commercialiser entre 7000 et
10000 € selon les options proposées
l'objet ne s'adresse pas qu'aux
professionnels bien au contraire en 2013
et 2014 le drone a été le cadeau
high-tech le plus offert à
Noël c'est la fin de notre émission je
vous donne rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
filco je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée